hi friends this week I am talking to a
theoretical physicist bit of a departure
from my usual sort of guests but she's
very interesting Sabina Hassan Felder is
a theoretical physicist blogger and
author her most recent book lost in math
how beauty leads physics astray talks
about physicists obsession with
beautiful theories and how this is
potentially leading to a restriction in
progress for physics overall now it
sounds like quite a nebulous and
difficult to define area and it turns
out that it actually is but we do a
pretty good job of working out just what
is happening in the physics world at the
moment what I found particularly
interesting was discovering just how
much politics influences physics to get
your research funded what the hurdles
are that you need to jump through and
who whose rings you need to kiss in
order to be supported it seems very
contradictory to think that a scientific
subject area requires people to play a
game akin to what you would presume in
wall street where you're sticking to the
right kinds of rhetorics and you're
pushing the correct narrative coming
from the right educational background
coming from the right conceptual
theoretical background really really
interesting and it was a whole world
that I didn't even know existed so here
we go
[Music]
Sabina Hassan Felder how are you today
I'm doing fine how are you very good
thank you
where are you in the world at the moment
I'm in Heidelberg that's like 100
kilometers south of Frankfurt all very
nice indeed
very nice so I want to get straight into
it you will be the first physicist which
we've featured on the podcast so you've
the weight of the entire world of
physics is resting at the moment I want
to ask a really fundamental question
it's been a really long time since we've
seen major breakthroughs in physics you
know global newsworthy breakthroughs is
there a reason why that's the case well
one of the reasons is probably that
you're reading the wrong news they have
been they have been a lot of
breakthroughs in physics what I'm mostly
concerned with are really the
foundations of physics so the biggest
breakthroughs in physics are the ones
that the Nobel Prizes are getting handed
out for and you fund a list of that on
the website of the Nobel Prize Academy
but I'm really talking about the
foundations of physics and there you are
right it has been a really long time
since there has been a breakthrough
where we have discovered something
really new I mean the stuff that has
made headlines like said that the direct
detection of gravitational waves or
neutrino masses between oxidation and so
on and so forth these old ideas that go
back at least 3040 in some cases a
hundred years so this is physical proof
of something which theoretically has
been around for a little while
yes okay so is it a case at all that
there's less stuff to discover in
quotation marks are we mapping so much
of physics that the remaining dark spots
on the map are limited or is it
something to do with the approach that
physicists have got at the moment or is
there a sticking block or a glass
ceiling that we've hit well that's a
very good question but how would I know
how would I know what
what is still left to discover what I
can tell you is that we have already
discovered a lot and that just means
that the easy things have been done you
know the stuff that you can measure in
your little laboratory with you and her
equipment and so on it's sort of that's
all been done that's the case in
experiment it's also the case in theory
development you know the easy things
have been tried so it's kind of natural
to expect that it will become more
difficult then on balance to that though
we also now have a lot of more people
working on it so that should help but
apparently it doesn't so we have at
least in the foundations of physics we
have at the mathematical structure of
the theories that were using right now
since the mid-1970s okay so the
low-hanging fruit to one degree or
another as low hanging as physics can
get I suppose has been has been gathered
to a large degree would you say that's
fair yes okay so what what's the what is
the current sticking point that we've
got at the moment is it technological is
it that the instrumentation that we're
using is it the mines as you say there's
more more people than ever are
dedicating their efforts towards physics
are they looking in the wrong place but
I do think that they are looking in the
wrong place but of course I don't know
you know I I don't know what's the right
thing to do but the question that we can
reasonably look at and try to answer is
whether they are using good scientific
methods that would give them the highest
probability of making progress and I
think that's just currently not the case
okay well let's expand on that then why
why is that not the case well we have
seen a lot of non results in the
foundations of physics in the last four
decades for example in the search for
dark matter this has been going on since
the mid-1980s that people have looked
for the rare interaction of the
dark matter particles with an alma mater
you can do this basically by building
large tanks of some stuff and then you
could detectors around this stuff and
try to measure these interactions and
people have tried but I haven't seen
anything
they have also looked for proton decay
that's a prediction of certain new
hypothesis
they have also of course looked for new
particles and particle colliders the
most popular ones are probably
supersymmetric partners of the already
known particles that hasn't worked out
either is that is that coming out of the
LHC well that's actually a long story I
mean supersymmetry is an idea that also
dates back to the late 1960s or
something okay people have but people
have looked for supersymmetry for
evidence of supersymmetry since at least
the 1990s and that didn't work out
indeed they should have seen it already
in the 1990s so they actually had data
that was just in conflict with the idea
that supersymmetry is obeyed by it by
the laws of nature and what then what
they did was not to say well we've ruled
out supersymmetry but they said well we
will just modify the theory and so they
added a new symmetry on top of it which
is called our parity so now we have
super symmetric models that obey this
additional symmetry called our parity
and that's compatible with observations
so far okay so how long okay how long do
you pursue down a root of trying to find
a physical manifestation that proves a
theory before before you actually say
well maybe the theory is just wrong
completely but you do it until you come
up with something better but but that's
the rap because it's really really hard
right now to come up with something
better in the sense that you can get
funding for it and collect sufficiently
many people so that certainly many
people agree it's
and that the problem is you have a
community like supersymmetry which for
the foundations of physics is a really
really large community you know you have
something like I don't know 1,000 or
2,000 people of that order of magnitude
and if you try to say well maybe that's
not the right path that's really hard to
get people to listen to and accordingly
it's also hard to get funding for it
yeah I can imagine so how much your
physics is about physics and how much
your physics is about politics there is
unfortunately a lot of politics not only
in physics but in science generally or
maybe you could call it psychology
mm-hmm you know you always have to think
about how do i how do I sell my research
to get other people to listen to it how
do I get other people to like it and of
course the easiest way to get other
people to like what you're doing is to
work on something that I like already
yeah and that you clearly see the
strength that people work on stuff that
other people like for sometimes not
entirely scientific reasons you know
supersymmetry has a reputation of being
a particularly pretty theory it has a
lot of aesthetic appeal to it that's
something that you hear for cysts who
work in these areas talk about very very
frequently and that's certainly one of
the reason why I'd attract so many
followers because people just like
working with it hmm can you briefly
explain to us what supersymmetry is
please supersymmetry is an extension of
the theories that we currently use we
have something that's called the
standard model of particle physics in
which we have 25 particles that for we
currently know make up all matter in the
universe and in this standard mode we
have two different types of Protocol's
they're called fermions and bosons and
they are just different things now
supersymmetry is a symmetry that relates
the fermions with the bosons so that
they actually belong together now the
problem is that from the particles that
we already have observed that are in the
standard model they do not pair up into
the proper super symmetric
so what you have to do if you believe in
supersymmetry is that you just postulate
there are new particles to find that
pair up with the ones that we have
already and then there's the question
where where are they
because we haven't seen them and the
answer to this is that they are so heavy
that we have not yet been able to
produce them in particle colliders okay
well it's um from a basic illogical
standpoint it does seem a little bit
like making the making the foot fit the
shoe as opposed to the other way around
and I guess it sounds like you for all
that physics and physicists have got
unbelievably logical brains there's a
lot of probably ego and dogma and
patriotism two particular approaches do
you think that that's restricting
physics and moving forwards this lack of
ability to let go of existing models and
potentially look elsewhere yes sure but
I should add that of course these ideas
do have certain scientific motivations
that got them started in the first point
and not just those in the air right no I
mean supersymmetry it was something that
attracted a lot of attention for example
because it comes out of string theory so
you if you believe in string theory you
actually need supersymmetry the opposite
is not necessarily true you know if you
if you have supersymmetry you don't
necessarily also need strings but since
there are a lot of people who like
string theory and they are kind of
forced to also have the supersymmetry so
that's one thing but supersymmetry is
also something that people like to work
with because it solves some mathematical
problems with the theories and that's
just something that they find appealing
it's it's also it turned out that if you
have the supersymmetry and you add our
parity to it then you get particles that
can also make up dark matter so that fit
very nicely with the story
but that was as I said it was something
like 30 years ago and since then the
situation has just changed you know and
I think that the appeal of supersymmetry
has dramatically fallen since because we
haven't seen it in the data yeah but
people keep adjusting their models so
they become more and more complicated to
address the lack of evidence that we
have yeah and then then at some point
you come to the question that you asked
like when it when do you stop you know
what when do you just conclude that
physicists are not able to let go of
their ideas because they have invested
too much time and effort into it does it
feel a little bit like flogging a dead
horse sometimes that's fantastic
so it's ok so it's what it means is you
you've taken every opportunity that you
can you've taken every route that you
can to try and distill from one thing
something else and that something else
hasn't worked therefore it's time to
move on it's a it's interesting that
that hasn't that hasn't crossed refer
into into your vernacular it's really
cool actually actually once read an old
book with idioms but I can't recall this
in any case so that that's interesting
question because if supersymmetry is not
the right thing that it means that that
physicists have made some wrong decision
pretty early on for that so we actually
yeah so we have to go back and ask if
one of the assumptions that entered all
these arguments that let them to work on
supersymmetry to begin with was maybe
the wrong path to take Wow so that's
potentially an awfully big upheaval in
the physics community I'm gonna guess
well you see people discussing this
right now so the argument that I make in
my book is that this believe in
naturalness
is an issue
and that's a problem that needs to be
rethought right now so naturalness is
this idea that the theories of physics
should only contain numbers without
units that are close to one not much
larger than one a lot much smaller than
one there are more complicated versions
of this but that's that's the ones the
easy case yeah
and that's something that they used to
construct theories and now it just
happens that supersymmetry obeys this
idea of naturalness it actually helps to
make the standard model natural so the
sin of all by itself is not natural but
if you add supersymmetry to it it works
and a lot of theoretical physicists take
that as strong evidence that there's
something true about supersymmetry that
it has power to describe nature and I
just think that that's a wrong
conclusion you know I see no reason why
the theories of nature should have this
property that they call naturalness okay
so in your book lost in math how beauty
leads physics astray you talk about this
this desire within the physics community
to have beautiful theories can you
describe what what is considered to make
a theory beautiful yes so it's
interesting that if you ask theoretical
physicists what they mean by beauty they
all more or less say the same thing so I
think this is not an idea of beauty that
you find find among non physicists but
for what physicists are concerned beauty
has three major ingredients the one is
simplicity and by this I mean that the
theory should be simple in absolute
terms I don't mean in in relative terms
where you say well I take the theory
that is simpler than some other theory
but achieves the same but but just that
the theory should have simple laws like
it should have unified first for example
is simpler than for different forces if
you add symmetry to a model that usually
combines two different concepts to one
or several different concepts like with
supersymmetry we already talked about
this where you have the fermions on the
bosons they actually belong together so
that that's a simplification in terms of
the axioms of your theory
so simplification is one aspect of
beauty then there's naturalness I
already told you about naturalness the
thing was the parameters that had no
units that should be of order 1 yep and
then the third aspect is something
that's usually referred to as elegance
and that's a kind of a fluffy criterion
so it's not something I heard I expected
to hear coming out of physics well it's
it's something that they talk about a
lot you actually find this also in a lot
of older literature like there's there's
a book by Chandra Sekhar Barry where he
goes all about this already but um so
what they mean with elegance is that the
theory should be simple but it shouldn't
be too simple so it should lead to some
interesting insights you should you
should have some AHA effect here and
there you know it shouldn't have
unexpected connections it should give
you some surprises so that's this idea
of elegance and you also find these
three aspects and a lot of artworks by
the way I mean simplicity is all well
and fine but if it's too simple it's
just boring and and so I think it's the
same sense that you find here that's
really interesting it sounds like
reducing the theory down to its simplest
simplest possible terms is is um does
this cause people to justice cause
physicists to look in the wrong places
sometimes when they're trying to develop
theories is this a an artifact of equals
mc-squared and other very very short
very very simple theories like that you
know I would actually say that e equals
MC square is too simple you know it's
not that's overshot it okay yeah yeah
but but that makes an interesting point
because the this sense of what is
elegant you know what is surprising what
what gives you some
you insights and so on depends of course
on how much you know already so the
sense of what counts as elegant and what
counts as beautiful changes throughout
the history of science li you find
evidence for this in the literature you
know when you look back several hundred
years they thought their planets on
circular orbits well that's a beautiful
idea because it turns out to be wrong
but that's an ideal of beauty that you
just wouldn't find today among
physicists it's something that no one
would pull upon and now they have other
ideas of beauty and well maybe these
work or maybe that these don't work we
just don't know so generally I think
it's a bad idea to impose our current
ideals of beauty on the laws of nature
in the sense that we use it to construct
new theories because the problem is you
know we were talking about these
experiments earlier where they look for
dark matter and the particle colliders
and I don't know some telescopes and so
on and so forth these are really closely
experiments and we just can't test all
theories that theoretical physicists
come up with so we have to make a
selection and of course we try to select
those theories that we consider to be
the most promising now if we make a bad
choice we go and test theories that are
wrong then the only thing we get are no
results now the null results are also
results of course but they are not very
useful results when you try to develop a
new theory so that that gets you stuck
in a cycle where looking at the wrong
theories gives you the results that gets
you stuck at the wrong theories and so
on and so forth yeah well and it's just
crossing one thing off the board as
opposed to directing you on towards the
right direction on the board yes exactly
yeah I mean it sounds in between the
potential for dogma this dogmatic err
and patriotic holding on to existing
bodies of knowledge or existing
directions within theories Plus this
desire for beautiful theories to come
out
must lead to a little bit of an echo
chamber and a lot of theories that are
similar and as you say you add a add a
section on to something which already
exists now this works
despite the experiment not showing
anything that supports it yes it's
certainly true
I think that's an organizational problem
where's the academic system in general
you know if you want to get something
funded if you want to get something
published it's much easier if you work
on something that people already work on
and and of course people know this so
that's that's what they do it's you know
in some sense it's not particularly
surprising what what is surprising is
that they accept this and play along
with it mmm yeah I understand so where
do we go from here do you have a do you
have a suggestion for how physicists can
look at the field in a different way
well sure I think the first step is that
they they become aware of what they are
doing so that they actually understand
where they are using assumptions from
beauty that are not scientific in some
cases I think people know this but in
other cases I'm pretty sure they don't
like this this idea of naturalness for
example I would say like half of the
people know that that it's not a
scientific criterion but the other half
thinks it is so it is clearly there's
something at odds there and there's also
this idea for example of unification or
the theory of everything I mean these
are all nice ideas but there isn't
really any good logical reason for why
there should be unified for us or for
why there should be a theory of
everything it's just something that
people work on because they like the
idea and so at some point we should draw
the conclusion that maybe that's not the
right path to work on and I think it
would help if they would just you know
take into account the arguments for and
against it when they write a paper say
or give a talk it
unfortunately it's very common that they
only list the arguments that speak for
their theory yeah like I can totally see
that you want to hear people it's a very
very educated version of yes man isn't
it they're having someone who just says
yes and agrees with what it is that your
your particular stance you you've
touched them something now that I did
want to discuss there was once upon a
time dream of a theory of everything or
a grand unification theory is that is
that a lost cause now does it seem to do
to the current state of theoretical
physics suggest that that's not the
direction that we're going to end up in
who knows I mean personally I think that
this whole idea of a theory of
everything doesn't make a lot of sense
because I mean suppose I tell you here's
the theory of everything and it explains
everything that we see how do you know
that it will still be a theory of
everything tomorrow you know that that
we will not at some point measure
something that does not fit into this
theory so I think that this is you know
it just doesn't make a lot of sense
conceptually then of course there is the
issue that what people in the
foundations of physics mean when they
say theory of everything does not
actually explain everything that's just
a way to say well we have combined all
the four known forces into one so so so
that's what they mean just just to get
the terminology started oh yeah
and that might still work out at some
point or it might not
I mean presently I think we just really
don't know personally I have developed
an interest in an approach that is
called as importantly save gravity it
basically solves the problem that we
have with the quantum properties of
space and time a body does not also
include a unification of the
interactions you know they you kind of
have a framework in which they all fit
but they are not unified in the way that
resists usually speak about
unification but that theory seems to be
working just fine
so presently I don't see any urgent
reason for why these forces should be
unified you know maybe our universe just
has four different forces and that's
that yeah what are the four forces
please well one of the forces is gravity
you all know gravity
there's electromagnetism and then
there's the strong in the weak nuclear
force and the odds are how much of that
has been pulled together because there's
obviously still conflict between certain
areas of that have you managed to unify
certain areas and others are still out
on a limb it kind of depends on what you
mean by unification so the
electromagnetic and the strong and the
weak nuclear force are kind of of the
same type and we describe them all with
the same mathematics basically in what
we call the standard model of particle
physics but they are not unified in the
sense that they are still three separate
forces yeah and then there's gravity
which is described by a different
mathematical framework so it doesn't
really fit together with the other three
forces usually that doesn't really
bother us because in the circumstances
where we use the standard model so we
describe collisions that have my
particle colitis then we are dealing
with elementary particles and the
gravitational force is so weak that we
don't have to worry about what to do
with gravity but there are certain
circumstances where it would be
necessary to take both of these theories
into account
like for example close to the center of
a black hole or something like that and
for in these cases we just don't have a
theory right okay so to a degree gravity
is the it's the black sheep of the punch
which is is it the most difficult to
make fit you said recently that we've
discovered experiments have managed to
detect gravitational waves is that
correct yes well that's not so reason
there was in 2015 okay
that's that's a long time ago well yeah
I mean the prediction dates back you
know eight years or something okay so
going back I'd mentioned there about
particle colliders and the LHC was
during the build-up to it was hailed as
by sensationalist press is something
that was going to create a black hole in
the middle of Europe and absorb the
entire world and then it didn't and then
what came out of it was the Higgs boson
was detected but since then this huge 23
mile round-trip experiment doesn't
really seem to have elicited much else
is that correct no that's not correct
I know Oh again as I said I think you're
reading the wrong news probably because
you're not a physicist so the the LHC
has detected the Higgs boson that's the
news that everyone has heard of but it
has also done a lot of other things it's
just that these did not make so big
headlines you know it has first example
probed the structure of the proton in
much much better details then was
previously known and found a few
surprises there people are working on it
it has also been able to measure a lot
of the constants in a standard model of
particle physics to much higher
precision than what was previously
possible
it has also measured a lot of composite
particles that are made of several
quarks and measure their properties so
it's not like nothing has been going on
besides the Higgs boson it's just that
the other stuff has not been quite as
exciting as producing a tiny black hole
that eats up Europe yeah well I mean
that would have made the news if it
happened they would have definitely if
they would have been still news then
yeah yeah exactly news in America
perhaps but that is I am right in saying
that that's the only new particle which
it found that's correct right the only
new fundamental particle yes okay is
there
a likelihood or is people still holding
out hope that it's going to find more or
again if we have a little bit of a glass
ceiling with with that particular oh yes
oh yes definitely there are still people
who think that supersymmetric particles
will eventually show up so the thing is
that this assumption of naturalness that
I was talking about earlier would have
put the supersymmetric particles in the
regime of fairly low energies close by
the hicks basically so we should have
seen them already okay so we know that
this idea of naturalness was just wrong
and it's gone out of the window but
nothing has replaced it and this means
that people who work on supersymmetry
basically now have no particular reason
to think that the particle should be at
any particular mass Kade so it could be
there in the data or it could not be
there there are definitely people who
think that it will be there and the LHC
has not totally analyzed all the data
that they have they're still collecting
data and you know getting better
statistics from which they try to
extract more details and so on and so
forth so there's there still hope that
they will find something new but the
early evidence would suggest not yes I
mean so far they haven't found anything
it's at seeds okay so moving on I wanted
to talk about dark matter or dark energy
and discuss why that's so important to
physicists to find that could you could
you explain just why it's such an
important concept within physics well
let me start with saying that dark
matter matter and dark energy are
totally different things so dark energy
is whatever is causing the accelerated
expansion of the universe you know
that's just a name that we gifted with
call it dark energy and personally I
think there's really nothing to explain
because these this acceleration of the
universe can just be described by the
Khan
that thing is called the cosmological
constant and you can't just go and
measure it and has a value that's it
you know there are people who think that
it should have some kind of microscopic
explanation you know it should be made
up of something basically and then there
is something to explain but I see no
reason for why this should be so so the
lines the lines drawn underneath dark
energy as far as you're concerned yes
unless you really show me some data that
cannot be fitted with that constant okay
but so far there isn't any and so far
the constant does a good job so then
there's the thing with dark matter dark
matter is stuff you know basically
similar to the stuff that we are made of
except that it does not interact with
light in any form so it does not absorb
it it does not emit it it doesn't
scatter it and it's believed to sit
around galaxies you know hover around
them in clouds and it plays a big role
in the formation formation of structures
in the universe that's for what the
simulations are concerned now the
problem with dark matter is that if you
believe it's made of a particle you want
to actually measure the particle and
that it has not happened then the other
option is that we actually do not need
any additional stuff but that we should
change the law of gravity so that it
gravity does not work the way that
Einstein envisioned it as with his
theory of general relativity
you know curvature of space-time and the
rubber sheet and so on and so forth but
that we need a different theory for
gravity and that's what's called
modified gravity maybe not the greatest
term ever that's what it's called and
ever since people came up with this idea
of modified gravity we have had two
camps the one is the big camp
that's the particle Dark Matter camp and
then there's a smaller camp of modified
gravity and the case still is not
settled I see but I'm right in thinking
that if it was proven that dark matter
didn't
if I guess I guess it's going to be very
difficult to prove that it doesn't exist
because there's always the potential to
continue detecting up until the point at
which you do detect it is that right is
it difficult to disprove a theory like
that some people are always going to
hold on to the hope that we finally do
detect it yes so it's basically
impossible to rule out because as you
say you can always I mean you build a
detector and the detector has a certain
sensitivity to some interaction
probability and so on and so forth and
then you can always just say well made
the particle maybe the perfect drug had
a lower probability of interaction than
what we have been able to probe so far
so we need to build a bigger detector in
the sensitivity oh yeah right and that's
been going on since the mid 90s and the
sensitivity has increased by at least a
factor of hundred thousand since oh my
god yeah and I mean you can continue to
play this game as long as you want as
long as you can get money for it so but
but again you know and the thing is that
the theories that we think are plausible
direct the efforts that we make in
testing the theories so if we invest
money in building more detectors for
dark matter we will we cannot invest the
same money into I don't know building
some telescope and put it on a satellite
and measure I don't know gravitational
lensing better or what-have-you
something that would allow us to test
modified gravity so we have we have
decisions to make and I think we have to
be really really careful as theoretical
physicists in how we rate the promise of
theory it's very interesting how
theoretical physicists and the relative
weight behind each of their theories
across all all of the different subject
areas sub-disciplines within physics is
having such an impact on the
experimenters and what they get to do
and where they can direct their efforts
that you guys are kind of like the roots
of the tree and from that determines
what can grow out of it to a degree
whereas it's it's interesting but it's
not really surprising is it I mean yeah
you have a lot of people in a community
and they basically only talk to each
other and they constantly tell each
other that what they are doing is
interesting and it's probably the right
thing and then then they believe it's
the right thing and of course there are
a lot of people they will be able to
convince other people that probably what
they're doing is the right thing and
then you have this small group of people
who work on you know just to pick this
example modified gravity or something
you know there may be a few dozen people
who work on this and they're full of
self-doubt not so surprisingly because a
huge number of really smart people is
working on something else it's like
constantly saying that modified gravity
is a joke and so the people who work on
it are like yeah you know they're really
really reluctant to make those big
proclamations that the other people have
no problem making yeah it's a that's
just you you have this back up you know
behind your back you have a large group
of people who support you yeah that
makes a big psychological difference 100
percent it must be I don't know it's
someone from the outside looking in I
would my goal or my my aim would be to
have to expedite the discovery of
whichever theory is correct
not to dogmatically stick to whichever
one is most popular and it seems that
it's definitely not for the benefit of
physics for anyone who's looking at
alternative theories to be ostracized or
to you know be ridiculed or whatever it
might be because if if that research is
the right direction and these people are
being reluctant or the you know
someone's in in the camp of the existing
model of of gravity and is thinking that
then it might not be right but they're
terrified of moving over because of what
their peers are going to say to them
that's not a tremendously holistic view
of holistic direction for physics to
take overall is it yeah well that's
certainly true the thing is of course
that if you would go and ask physicists
they would deny that this is
what's going on you know because they
they are too smart to fall for mistakes
like this and of course they have good
reasons to work on what they work on and
so on it's worth so so they they think
that they are they are not biased they
cannot possibly be biased by the size of
the group that they work on it's just
that's just a possibility that's not on
their radar
you know what sport for the physicist
sociology and psychology are not real
sciences it's not something that they
pay attention to they think it's not
necessary which is crazy because it's it
would appear that an obvious and obvious
example of groupthink is going on here
you have you have this Eckhart you have
this echo chamber you have people that
support theories that it would appear
have more and more experiments proving
nothing to support them and no one being
prepared to move in a different
direction it's so interesting how as you
say that the guy the people that are in
the field of physics are so clever and
yet fundamentally appear to perhaps be
unable to see the wood for the trees a
little bit here yeah maybe well you say
that it's an obvious example for
groupthink but I would be more careful
there I would say there's a possibility
that it is grouping which cannot be
ruled out because the current
organization of the research does not
guard scientists for falling for it they
address are no measures against it it's
indeed it's actually the opposite that
the current organization of research
supports this group thing because as I
said earlier it's easier for people to
get funding to get positions if they
work in what is already a large group so
you know I I don't really know what's
going on maybe there's nothing wrong
whatsoever but either way I think that
we should institutionalize some measures
that prevent people from falling into
this groupthink trap that's interesting
so how do you suggest that you
institution
well one of the things I already said
briefly previously it's that I think
that scientists generally not just
physicists need an awareness for these
cognitive and social biases that you
develop when you work in large groups
it's just something that people should
know of you know so that they can
recognize what's going on like this
visual thinking or loss awareness that
we already talked about you know that's
this reluctance to abandon a research
project that you have been working on
for a long time just because you have
invested a lot of effort into it
so I mean there's a long long list of
these things that you know basically you
can print them and hand them out to
students or something like that I mean
something really trivial but then there
are other things that have to be done by
funding agencies basically we already
previously talked about this problem
that it's really hard to get out of a
research area if you notice that maybe
it's not the best thing to work on yeah
and and the major problem is that you
have all your expertise in what you have
previously worked on so nobody will give
you money to do something else they will
not hire you you will not get grants
it's just in the current organization
it's not possible so - so it's not
surprising that people continue to do
what they are already doing because they
wouldn't be able to do something as you
know they wouldn't have money to pay the
rent exactly and there are simple things
that you can do to avoid this problem
you know by offering people some kind of
re-education support you know you could
say well you know you you want to change
fields and there are one-year
scholarships or something something in
which you will be supported I mean maybe
not with the greatest pay but you have
you have one year or two years or
whatever it depends on the field of time
of learning the basics of a new area you
know time in which you are not in which
you do not have to produce new results
or something like that for sure and do
you think that that would allow a more
free-flowing of
talent between different areas and
different sub disciplines I definitely
think so I mean I can only see positive
consequences of this and there are a few
other things that I have noted down in
in the appendix of my book but really
the point is that this is something that
people in these communities should think
about you know and they should come up
with a list of changes that they want to
implement and then just pull it through
or at least try to so the major problem
right now is that that no one takes
these problems seriously to begin with
mhm yeah it's um it's really funny what
you said about physicists wouldn't see
psychology and sociology as real
sciences and yet it would appear that
those are influencing their their
ability to move forward perhaps an awful
lot more than they actually might think
cognitive biases are leading them
potentially into I think you described
it as cul-de-sacs in the book where they
almost can't get themselves out again
we've we've touched on it a number of
times throughout throughout this where
the combination of this echo chamber and
then you're getting backed in by
financial financial restrictions and
also you've got this the weight of the
existing rhetoric the direction of this
particular this particular field that
you're working within and all of the
social influences that you've got from
people in there it must be it must be a
difficult situation for a number of
physicists to work in at the moment who
may want to make this move or who may
want to expand their body of knowledge
to a different area or an alternative
theory but just feel like they can't do
it yes sure a lot of them just leave you
know I've seen people leave I mean it's
you see these are people who figure out
that they will not be able to get money
to work on the research that they think
is most promising and then they just
conclude then it's not worth that time
so they just leave like a dhimmi and do
something else and you know there is
life outside of academia too it's like a
terrible shame to lose fantastic talent
in the in the field of academia because
of this sort of systemic dogma yes it's
a shame but it's also just a problem for
science because of course they're the
people that are left are the ones who
who don't have big problems with joining
these large research programs and just
producing papers you know if they had a
large problem with it then they were
believing yeah yeah for sure but it's
not necessarily the best for the subject
the body of knowledge as a whole right
people could be doing something a lot
more productive if if it was a little
bit more free-flowing I I think so you
know this is why I hope that making some
organizational changes to academic
research would help overcome this
impasse for sure for sure
so Sabina I really appreciate your time
would you be able to tell the listeners
where they can find you online I'll make
sure that I put a link to lost in math
how beauty leads physics Australia
booked in the show notes below but where
can they find you online I really like
your blog so you need to put that in
well it's not complicated you know for
all I know there's only one person with
my name you type it into Google and like
the first 100 hits will actually direct
you to my websites I have a website
that's called Sabina Hassan Federer calm
it's not hard to remember if you can
remember my name I have a blog that's
called back reaction and that's a blog
spot.com and I'm also on Facebook and
I'm on Twitter and I write for a lot of
websites every now and then so you will
find all this my help of google or
reviewers search engine of choice
fantastic
Sabina I really appreciate your time I
hope that we've opened some people's
eyes to what the physics community's
like at the moment I hope this doesn't
sound like a disparaging criticism of
what's going on within there you know
it's it's obviously a very difficult
subject for everybody to wrap their
heads around even the best minds in the
world but I do think it's so interesting
what you've said about these social
influences and cognitive biases
influencing who we consider to be the
some of the cleverest people on the
planet and in a weird way I think it's
actually a little bit um it's a little
bit reassuring that for us normal normal
people who perhaps aren't aren't at the
level of a theoretical physicist that
they are still subject to these these
psychological and sociological
influences oh my god you just found out
that physicists are humans yeah I did do
you know what it is sometimes like
sometimes I'm not sure but I think I did
so thank you very much for your time
Sabina I'll make sure everything's in
the show notes below thank you very much
thank you you're welcome
[Music]